the thing I've noticed about
underestimated founders aka
under-represented founders aka black
brown latin women is it Latin X is that
the right term now am I yeah like next
so that we can do that Brown Latin X and
LGBTQ as well that's what your invest in
as a mandate yeah and if you look at
those groups the valuations will be
lower for higher performance well that
might have been true a few years ago and
I I understand what you're saying I just
want to be very clear I'm not saying it
should be that way but I think they are
still underestimated the valuation
itself might be back to almost the
here's the thing is that the valuation
it's it's where they are let me see how
do I put this because if you say that
just directly if somebody were to take
that sentence out yeah they may say okay
where they're just not as good a company
right we're talking about amazing
companies we're talking about I want to
give an example because I think it'll be
helpful can I can I do that yeah I'm
packed okay so I'll give an example and
I'll try to do it blindly because it's I
can't say too much about it but there is
a company that that is doing as a
telecom company and so they have
satellites that they're putting together
that they put together the black male
founder and you may recognize this but
the black male founder 16 years ago
developed a technology that lets these
satellites go into space or less objects
go into space for longer because it the
the the technology cools the objects
faster right and for longer so he sold
that to a major company ten years later
and then a few years later started this
current company that we're invested in
in 2017 and he used he uses the same
technology that he built and invented 16
years ago sold to a major company uses
that same technology now for the telecom
company to send in satellites the same
and I know you're friends with Elon Musk
and and I think this founder drives a
Tesla so there's there's no you know
there's love there yeah but the same
12,000 satellites that it takes StarLink
star links to put into orbit 12,000
in this consolation they can do for 12
satellites 12 and have more coverage so
all of that is to say and in there and
they're backed by three major funds we
were there we were in before those funds
right and they're going to most likely
be a nine figure valuation next year and
it's so given that and you have that
early relationship when you go to them
and say hey you got another round I know
you're over subscribed or you know it's
going to be tight can backstage get an
allocation they're gonna for 250 or 500
like well you gave me twenty five when I
needed it 100 percent you don't get
boxed at a deals which is exactly the
experience I've had over the last ten
years which is you know if you're the
first check-in or early check-in the
founders always got real love for you
and the special place I just think you
know the still to this day I see
companies with less performance get
higher valuations or the same valuation
that an underrepresented founder with
more performance and that's a man a
cynical way to look at it would be
arbitrage but you know like you
literally invest in two female companies
for the price of a male company with the
same performance just to be real I can
tell you I objectively see that not
universally but I see it often and it's
bizarre so I don't have to just argue
what I would argue there is what you're
saying is not wrong it's not inaccurate
right but well the way I would say it is
because you have to understand 60% 70%
of your audience is going to hear that
and then automatically just because of
an unconscious bias is gonna think means
that means that those women have a worst
case thing so instead we say those two
women their companies are properly
priced
and the other people are boner valued
overvalued I like that I like the flavor
that means that you're paying too much
and you're throwing money away you like
it I like it I like the framing we and
you know that then you also the great
advantage you have now is now that
you've built this brand I would suppose
in your 5 of investing your you'll
probably have a similar experience to
what I have which is instead of chasing
and looking for deals going out and
hunting
you've become a sorter of deals people
just email you all the best deals and
you're on the top of the list if you're
an underrepresented founder well of
course you want Arlen's money of course
you want that checkbox because she knows
the space and she's gonna help validate
what you're doing so is your life
chasing deals now are sorting through
them as they come in I would I if I
didn't want to I would never have to go
seek source a deal for the rest of my
life at this point just crazy
we have insane deal flow and we have
deal flow we have people who pitch us
who are white men you are doing well
because they think they can convince us
to like you know change our minds for a
second no our deal flow is is as out of
this world and it's also its quantity
and quality you know so it's we do a lot
of I think a lot of that is in the work
that we do with the 98% that we don't
invest in because that builds up a
certain character and a certain
reputation and it's a lot of work
especially when you're under you're
under resource like we are but it's so
worth it in the long run well in in a
way when you think about it it makes
sense although a lot of investors miss
what you just said which is your
definite your your reputation is defined
by the people you say no to more than
the people you say yes to the people you
say yes to of course love you you gave
them money you supported them you
validated them and you went on the
journey with them the people you say no
to well they're hurt right you know I
didn't make the cut but if you're kind
to them and supportive of them then they
go out and say you know what it wasn't a
fit for our Lin or Jason but we did you
know they they were particularly helpful
in these ways